so what have we found is some of the
barriers at in touch because certainly
there are there are adoption barriers to
use and as you saw the rp7 robot up
there at barnes-jewish hospital one of
the things that we found is of every ten
doctors that are using our system our
robot actually about four of them really
love it they love using a joystick and
driving it around and they actually are
into that another three or four are sort
of indifferent to the experience and
then two or three say you know I will
never touch that can I like the nurse to
push me to the side of the bed and and
then I'll deliver the care that way so
so we've had to address those barriers
certainly as we've started thinking
about new enabling technologies and
we're about to share with you our PV
tahir and yuen wong is going to share a
little bit more about it but really what
it comes down to is is is this question
which is you know what what is the
future of healthcare and does anybody
know what this what this represents on
the screen who knows what that is
Prometheus it's the it's the health pod
from Prometheus right so and a rather
grotesque scene where where a caesarean
section is being delivered through an
autonomous robot that's certainly not
what we believe the future of health
care is well it's an interesting and
provocative seen you and I think is
going to share with you a little bit
more about the vision of where we see
rp-vita